aux etats unis maintenant après le
meurtre tragique de john floyd un
véritable débat une prise de conscience
refait surface sur la question raciale
politiciens et activiste repenser
certaines lois
on parle même de démanteler de retirer
le financement au service de police dans
certaines villes comme minneapolis ce
soir où vous présente un entretien
exclusif en français avec une des
militantes afro américaines les plus
influentes aux états unis angela davis
la lutte depuis plus de 50 ans pour
l'égalité raciale et toute forme
d'oppression contre les minorités
[Musique]
né en 1944 à birmingham dans une
amérique ségrégationniste et raciste
angela davis et le visage de la lutte
pour les droits civiques aux etats unis
parmi ses souvenirs d'enfance le ku klux
kahn qui fait exploser les maisons des
noirs américains
tout de suite elle milite auprès des
black panthers épouser la cause
communiste tout en terminant son
doctorat en philosophie en 1969 avec sa
célèbre coupe afro elle devient
rapidement une icône du mouvement des
noirs américains
j'étais un symbole qu'il fallait
détruire dira-t-elle plus tard en 1970
elle est sur la liste des femmes les
plus recherchés du fbi haye elle est
accusée injustement de meurtres et
d'enlèvements dans un attentat visant à
libérer des prisonniers politiques noirs
elle est arrêtée et fait face à la peine
de mort
s'ensuit alors un mouvement
international qui réclame
[Musique]
john lennon et yoko ono enregistre la
chanson en virage là
en france jean paul sartre aragon
foucault font pression après seize mois
de détention a libéré avec le fameux
poing en l'air
aujourd'hui elle continue de militer
pour l'égalité des femmes contre le
racisme contre l'oppression et pour
l'abolition de la peine de mort
[Musique]
angela davis bonsoir merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous ce soir bonsoir
quel regard portez-vous là surtout le
mouvement qui a été déclenché après la
mort de georges frêche c'est la première
fois que nous avons vu une telle réponse
immédiate à une intel à me troll assises
presque partout dans le monde et c'est
bien sûr à cause de la nouvelle
technologie de communication nous avons
tous collectivement
regardez les dernières minutes la vie de
george clooney
mais une telle réponse était possible
précisément à cause du fait que la
brutalité racice policiens existe aussi
on leur a embrasé aussi au canada
c'est un problème mondial et je crois
que nous devons créer une solidarité
mondiale et je crois que cette
solidarité peut-être créer la base pour
un espoir de changement
madame davis si on regarde les 50
dernières années il ya eu la fin de
l'apartheid il ya eu également
l'élection d'un premier président afro
américain aux états unis donc on sentait
qu'on était le racisme c'était quelque
chose du passé et puis là en 2020 on à
la mort terrible de john floyd est ce
que c'est un réveil brutal est ce qu'on
s'est un peu reposé sur nos lauriers en
longueur le disco populaire
c'est dire que le racisme était déjà
éliminé un bien sûr que l'élection de
barack obama a servi d'exemple de la
fausse idée qu'il n'y avait plus de
racisme mais je crois que cette
conception de racisme elle même était
fausse
le racisme est beaucoup plus que des
habitudes individuelles
l'adjectif racice étaient utilisées et
continue d'être utilisé pour décrire
et les individus des dvd des personnes
individuelles à mèze à l'autre côté nous
avons dit pendant mes derniers cinquante
ans que le racisme mais pas seulement
ancré dans les attitudes le racisme est
structurelle et les systémique
il est institutionnel et les mettre dans
la peau liste de georges frêche est le
maître de ahmad ambri par des ministres
à 6 ans tu étais le réveil c'est
beaucoup plus difficile de faire des
changements alors dans le racisme
système et qu'on a aussi un débat ici au
québec au canada sur le racisme
systémique
ça va prendre plus de temps pour le
changer ce que vous avez vous avez
espoir que ça puisse changer
oui j'ai eu l'espoir que ça va changer
mais pas dans un instant d'abord c'est
absolument extraordinaire que des
prothèses continue ici en amérique du
nord mais aussi en europe et en amérique
du sud pour changer les institutions
nous aurions besoin de beaucoup plus que
les réformes les prisons et les
départements de police ont été
perpétuellement réformer et après les
réformes ces institutions en devenu même
plus violent plus rassise plus permanent
c'est la raison pourquoi je crois les
activision demande l'abolition des
prisons ils disent qu'il faut des mois
tu es la police c'est à dire créer les
nouvelles institutions
imaginez un nouvel ordre
au delà du capitalisme raciale
capitalisme global
[Musique]
poursuivre l'entrevue avec angela davis
et vous allez voir dans un instant un
extrait d'un discours qu'elle prononçait
en 1972 mais c'est un discours qui est
malheureusement toujours d'actualité
le plus beau fumoir contre lui vingt six
hommes droite un bal angels michael
pieper os belle le poste victhom
hopeless la lutte nationale le centre
c'était en 1972 nous sommes en 2020 et
on a l'impression qu'on est face au même
problème c'est le même problème mais je
crois que à l'énergie de la jeunesse les
leçons que nous avons apprises pendant
les mouvements que nous avons créé
atteint 106 par la même chose alors nous
avons un terrain qui est tout à fait
nouveau nous avons un vocabulaire qui
est nouveau
alors c'est pourquoi je je je crois que
maintenant c'est le temps pour un espoir
réel
vous avez été activistes vous êtes
encore activistes féministes ou fait
partie de cette génération qui a buté
pour les droits des droits de la
personne
comment expliquer l'élection de dans
notre chambre après barack obama j'ai
même pas prononcer le nom de l'homme qui
était présidente vous pas j'hésite
quand quelqu'un comme le président dit à
ceux qui qui qui qui souffrent vraiment
que la raison pour laquelle vous
souffrez c7 à cause d aider des
immigrants mexique c'est à cause des
noirs
c'est à cause de l'action affirmatif
c'est la démagogie qui a créé consolider
le racisme
aujourd'hui vous avez des élections
angela davis dans quatre mois aux etats
unis
est ce que c'est important que les gens
évidemment vote
mais selon vous est ce que joe biden
pourrait être la solution
bon alors il faut voter il faut il faut
que le président qui est aujourd'hui
dans dans la maison blanche il faut qu
il qu'il puisse en a est selon vous le
changement ça ne passe pas
nécessairement par le politique
je ne crois pas que la politique
électorale et le meilleur espace pour
exprimer une politique radicale
je crois que les organisations black
eyes malheur à les jeunes
les protéger c'est ça qui va changer le
monde et c'est la première fois je crois
dans un autre histoire que beaucoup de
personnes blanches reconnaître elle
c'est sur cette collation
c'est une demande radical pour la
démocratie contre le racisme contre le
sexisme contre l'homophobie transphobie
la discrimination économique et points
pour beaucoup entre nous contre le
capitalisme et surtout pour la santé de
la planète et je crois que c'est la
raison pourquoi tout le monde partout
regarde ce mouvement comme l'espoir de
tous
c'est la première fois que nous avons
achevé un espèce de consensus
un consensus qui est beaucoup plus
radical que dans dans le passé est ce
que la situation des afro américains des
personnes noires
selon vous c'est s'est améliorée pas
collectivement il ya des changements en
clients d'edf et je crois que ce que que
c'est bien mais fondane fondamentalement
fondamentalement sommes rien n'a changé
il ya les institutions parle de la
diversité est bien sûr il ya plus de
gens qui représentent des communautés à
racialiser dans les institutions et
qu'on a mis tant dans les années 20
université mais les institutions elles
mêmes n'ont pas changé alors et c'est
une contradiction si si si vous intégrez
quelqu'un qui a été marginalisé et on le
passé dans une instit par une
institution et l'institution reste le
même qu'elle était quand il y avait
cette marginalisation
alors ça m'a fondamentalement rien de
changé alors c'est le temps maintenant
de commencer de changer les institutions
et selon vous à elles vont ces
institutions là vont céder à la pression
populaire
je crois j'espère j'espère angela davis
merci beaucoup merci infiniment merci
merci pour l'avoir mérité